مرحبا بكم في هذه الفقره الانسانيه الخاصه
بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه سينضم
الينا من غزه الدكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه ونسلط الضوء على
الاستهداف الممنهج
والمتواصل للاحتلال في تدمير القطاع الطبي
في غزه وقبل الدخول في الحوار نذكر بحصي
الشهداء في قطاع غزه بعد مرور 74 يوما على
الحرب الاسرائيليه اذ ارتفعت حصيله
العدوان الاسرائيلي الى
و67 شهيدا والجرحى الى اكثر من
5256 مصابا منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي وقد اشارت وزاره الصحه الى
ان 70% من الضحايا من الشهداء هم
والمصابين هم من الاطفال والنساء
الان بالارقام نستعرض خسائر القطاع الطبي
في قطاع غزه
22 مستشفى خارج الخدمه بفعل قصف الاحتلال
138 مؤسسه صحيه ايضا خارج الخدمه 52 مركزا
صحيا ايضا خارج الخدمه 100 سياره اسعاف
مدمره بطبيعه الحال اكثر من 100 سياره
اسعاف مدمره تقريبا 102 من سيارات
الاسعافيه مدمره
310 شهداء من الطاقم الطبي في قطاع غزه
93 موظفا صحيا معتقلا على راسهم مديران
مستشفيي شمال غزه الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه
والدكتور احمد الكحلوت خمسه الاف جريح
بحاجه ايضا
للعلاج خارج غزه نعود بهذه المعطيات
والارقام الى غزه مع الدكتور اشرف القدره
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه دكتور
اشرف ما الذي تعنيه هذه الارقام وفقدان
القطاع الطبي خاصه في منطقه الشمال شمال
القطاع
لمعظم
مرافقه نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم من
الواضح ان هذه الارقام تعكس ان رغبه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في تصفيه الوجود
الصحي وخاصه في شمال قطاع غزه والان اكمل
هذه الرغبه بانهاء تام لكافه الخدمات
الصحيه شمال قطاع غزه بعد ان تم سقوط
مستشفى المعمداني بالكامل وخروجه عن
الخدمه وهو المؤسسه الاخيره التي تسقط
وتخرج عن الخدمه في منطقه شمال غزه
وبالتالي الان اكثر من 800000 نسمه باتوا
بلا رعايه صحيه في شمال قطاع غزه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يزيد من المجازر وهو يدرك انه
لا وجود لخدمات صحيه لانقاذ الجرحى وهذا
يعني ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يضع السكان
بين خيارين الخيار الاول اما القتل وذلك
من خلال الاستهداف المباشر او من خلال عدم
توفر الرعايه الصحيه او النزوح الى خارج
منطقه شمال غزه باتجاه الجنوب وبالتالي
الواقع الصحي في قطاع غزه كارثه للغايه
منطقه الشمال لا يتو ض بها رعايه صحيه على
الاطلاق منطقه الجنوب ايضا بفعل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وخنق المنظومه الصحيه والتحكم
في مسار وحجم المساعدات الطبيه التي تدخل
يجعل المنظومه الصحيه في حاله انهيار
مستمر حيث ان مستشفيات جنوب قطاع غزه
اليوم عاجزه تماما عن التعامل مع الحجم
الهائل من الاصابات ونوعيه الاصابات التي
تصل بعد ان استخدم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اسلحه تدميريه في تدمير المنازل والاحياء
السكنيه حيث رات الطواقم الطبيه وعاينت
بنفسها ان الحالات التي تصل اليها بها
تشوهات من الدرجه الثالثه والرابعه وحروق
كبيره اضافه الى اذابه في الاطراف السفليه
والعلويه بتر في الاطراف السفليه والعلويه
تشوهات كامله جروح عميقه متفتت وبالتالي
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هو يدرك تماما ان هذه
المنظومه اصلا في الاساس هشه نتيجه الحصار
الاسرائيلي وفقدانها لكل مقوماتها الصحيه
ومع دخول العدوان الاسرائيلي قام بخنق هذه
المنظومه الصحيه وقطع الامدادات الطبيه
عنها وقام باستهدافها حتى لا ت لا تستطيع
انقاذ حياه الجاه دكتور اشرف من خلال
متابعتك ل كيفيه تعاطي المنظمات خاصه
المنظمات الصحيه الامميه مع تقييمها لهذه
الحاله التي يعيشها القطاع مع عمليه
التدمير الممنهج للقطاع الطبي كيف ترصد
هذه
المقاربات وعمليه التحريك التي تحاول ان
تحركها هذه المنظمات الامميه عندما تتحدث
بالارقام عن ما يجري في
القطاع للاسف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم يدع
لهذه المؤسسات الامميه دورا في قطاع غزه
من اجل انقاذ المنظومه الصحيه فهي ارهنت
لقرارات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ لظه
الاولى لهذا العدوان وغادرت منطقه شمال
غزه بشكل كامل وابقت السكان دون رعايه
صحيه او خدمه صحيه او حمايه صحيه للمؤسسات
او ايضا للطواقم الطبيه والنازحين في
المؤسسات الصحيه اضافه الى ان هذه
المؤسسات للاسف لم تقم بدورها في تفعيل
القانون الدولي الانساني واتفاقيه جنيف
الرابعه والذي يعطيها الفرصه الكامله
للقيام بمهامها الانسانيه سواء في تطبيق
المهام الانسانيه على المدنيين والنازحين
او في تطبيق هذه المهام الانسانيه في
حمايه المنظومه الصحيه وطواقمها التي
تستباح ليلا نهارا وبالتالي نحن اصبنا
بخيبه امل من هذه المؤسسات الامميه التي
عجزت تماما عن القيام بواجبها ومهامها
الانسانيه في قطاع غزه اضافه الى انها لم
تبادر في ايجاد اليات تضمن لنفسها القيام
بمهامها الانسانيه في ظل تعنت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ورفضه اعطاء الفرصه لها للقيام
بمهامها الانسانيه وهي التي قالت منذ
اللحظه الاولى بان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يرفض كل
اوجه المهام الانسانيه في قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هذه المؤسسات يجب ان ترته لذلك
وان تقوم بواجبها وان تجد لنفسها الياض
ضامن دكتور اشرف الونر وهي تتابع وتعمل في
القطاع منذ سنين طويله وتتابع ما يجري
حذرت اليوم بان 45% من الاطفال داخل
القطاع هم معرضون للخطر بسبب
انتشار الاوبئه الى اي درجه مثل هذا
المعطى معطى
فعليا يعني هو مخيف وقد يحدث لا سمح الله
على ارض الواقع ان لم يتم
تداركه هذه الارقام مخيفه جدا ومجتمع قطاع
غزه مقبل على كارثه صحيه وانسانيه كبيره
لانه لا تتوفر خدمات صحيه وانسانيه سواء
لمليون وث 100000 نازح او الذين ايضا هم
بقوا في اماكنهم لا يكت لا لا يمكن ان
تكتفي الامم المتحده ونروى لان تعطي
تقارير حول الوضع الانساني يجب ان ان يكون
لها اليات تمع وقوع الكارثه وليست فقط
تحلل المشهد الميداني او الصحي في داخل
قطاع غزه نحن نتحدث عن مؤسسه امميه هذه
المؤسسه يجب ان تاخذ لنفسها خطوات تضمن
عدم وجود الكارثه لا يمكن لهذه هذه
المؤسسات ان تبقى مكتوفه الايدي وهي اعلى
مؤسسات دوليه وامم وبالتالي عليها
التزامات اخلاقيه ووظيفه يجب ان تقوم بها
في داخل قطاع غزه لمنع الكارثه سواء
للاطفال او للسيادات الحوامل او ايضا
للمرضى المزمنين وكاله الغوث ادارت ظهرها
ل 70% من سكان قطاع غزه من فئه اللاجئين
وبالتالي لم تقدم الرعايه الصحيه
والانسانيه المطلوبه لهؤلاء المواطنين وال
واللاجئين شكرا لك دكتور اشرف القدره
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه حدثنا من غزه
ختام هذه الفقره الانسانيه الخاصه
بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على غزه نعود الى
غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه التغطيه المستمره